where are you right now and can i come
and like craft with you
please do i am in my uh my my happy
place my craft room
which uh yes it's my sanctuary
oh my gosh um i was watching your new
movie
this weekend and uh you're
blossoming into such a woman and
as the fact that we were both kind of
like
well we both weren't kind of we were
kids who grew up in this business
and do you see yourself as an adult yet
do you still feel like you're playing
house what is our deal
i know well i think that i've always um
been a child at heart and now i i feel
like
um i am kind of the happiest because i
get to be a kid
but i'm the adult so like i can have a
craft room
and you know i can be responsible and
still be my kid self
i remember like people thinking that i
was a kid for a really long time and i
didn't get that i was like no i
feel like an adult you and i stand
within your situation
because you were so famous at such a
young age and
and you know working with child actors i
didn't work as
much as you did as a kid but um there is
this
like need to be a lot older and more
sophisticated than
you would be you know at school on a
playground
um so i could see why you're like well
wait no i've just been doing this my i'm
an adult
at you know eight yeah like i forget
that
well we were both in commercials as kids
i got teased so
much about that commercial that it sort
of traumatized me a little bit
and i hadn't auditioned for like a
feminine hygiene prod product right
after that while i was airing
and i was already so mortified about
just talking about my dad's indigestion
i went to the audition and i read the
sides and it was all about oh my heavy
flow and what do i do
and i was like i can't do this i can't
even talk about my dad's indigestion
i love this story so much i
can't even tell you i've talked about
how i like my mom would get me
filet-o-fish every audition
i didn't get um which was like because
then she was like also like watch your
weight but here's affiliate fish it was
really confusing
yeah it's exactly i was in this
commercial as a kid
i know what kids do to you
when you do dip into school and it's
merciless like you and you don't feel
like you can complain about it because
we have these amazing lives and we don't
want to be like home school
is hard on us i swear these kids are
relentless well then i would go to
school the next day and they'd be like
do you think you're special
because you got to skip school yesterday
and act with snack
crackle and pop
you know what we made it we're adults
we're we're moms we're getting to
play moms you have been happily married
for 17
years i know i know and
he was really slow to propose so we've
actually been together
like oh 20 plus years
i was like if we proposed earlier we
could have like been celebrating our
20th
wedding anniversary i still hold him to
that
because i sort of knew right away i was
like yeah let's go
and he was super slow how was like your
quarantine year even though it's still
going on
yes i mean you know it's the roller
coaster but i certainly
um it could be a lot worse we really
like being together as a family which is
a plus
and um and you know we
i just i'm really good at like sort of
making
the best out of a situation so when it
first started i was like
girls we get to walk to school now so we
leave the front door and then go to the
side door and we'd sing this like
you know song about not getting corona a
virus and
you know like stuff like that so uh so
obviously it's there have been difficult
you know days and and as well um
but overall i try to sort of realize
that this is
time that when they're in college i'm
going to be like
remember when they couldn't leave the
house it was so nice
yeah i know it's so true i don't want
them to ever leave i keep having
fantasies like olive could go to college
down the street but like still live at
home
yeah the key to that is great snacks you
have to have like things that they're
excited about
yeah so that's why i get all like crazy
with my crafting
food and stuff